it's a the overwhelming and very
humbling and you can't quite process it
it's just it's very surreal but and it's
and it's one of those moments the minute
it's gone you go oh god I wish I'd
thought of saying something funny or
just not just but you just go stand
there going I cut you know it's this
wave of support and you know and
enthusiasm and love for it you're in its
the biggest home crowd I'll ever have I
think and it's just yeah it's this
quickest it's wicked and it you know
it's all about the fans so to be able to
show well I say show them I mean it was
I've never seen it either so to share
seeing with them for the first time that
footage and the trailer it's just it's
great it's what it's all about it's
giving something back and their devotion
with cosplay with waiting in line for
millenia for traveling all over the
world to be here you know they really
deserve what they get and I hope they
were happy we were in rehearsing my
little entrance today and I went out
said I think they've been oh yeah they
mean here all day and I was like what
yeah in the heat yeah and they're good
as a cue all night yeah I was like oh
this is ridiculous oh can I just go over
and talk to some of them and thank them
and say well done I mean it's ridiculous
and I did a little bit of hell broke
loose and it was lovely it was really
nice it was just nice to sort of see
people up close and just say thank you
well never tried it before so I didn't
know what to expect I've done other
Comic Cons which are great and fantastic
but this is apparently the one and well
you can tell people come here with a
product and it's highly anticipated and
there's a lot of love in the room let's
put it that way if we're up there and
we're presenting something that's new to
us and use to them but they are already
embracing it and screaming and shouting
and then something else pops up and you
hear an enormous scream and you're not
really sure what that is but apparently
it's enormous right so I mean that this
is definitely a Marvel films has to be
so grateful for their fanbase because
they are so dedicated I've never seen
anything like it
we have a clip that obviously audios
have not seen and neither had we so for
us I'm not sure we really took in the
reaction from the audience because we
saw it for the first time
and it is a film with a lot of magic and
we've been standing there doing our
gestures for front of a green screen so
we were just very pleased that it didn't
turn out there was just a door opening
and closing his background was actually
very magical the fantastic honor of
watching the trailer it's sort of six
feet close to you and just feeling the
love with everyone's just so passionate
and willingness for our movie and it's
lovely to see the fruits of our labor on
screen and and what scott derrickson has
really been up to and the this author
and visionary of showing us what this
world is like and the idea of astral
projection and you know bringing us
bringing us into you know to set the
tone of what our movie is about it just
really felt the love is a little bit
terrifying I mean like seven thousand
the screaming love but yeah it's kind of
yeah
I'm happy to be on stage with it it was
such a great buzz and and so much just
so much fun to do and I was really
really just really glad to be here and
be able to show the trailer to people
and and especially that crowd of people
because they were just so behind it and
so it was really exciting I'm so
intrigued by it you know like because
you know obviously in the process of
shooting it is one thing and then you
have some sense of what it's going to be
like in its kind of visual style and
language and then you get a chance to
see bits of it and you know I just feel
like that just I think Scott's just
doing an amazing job with the film and
and it's so unique and bold and quite
beautiful and so I think those things
are great I'm really excited for it it's
so broad as well and there's so many
great characters and great films and you
know I mean I was a huge fan I mean like
everybody else and it's such a huge fan
of the way that Guardians just kind of
went off in a kind of different
direction and like and I feel like this
film has some of that sort of in a
completely different way and so you know
I love that I love the scope of it I
love how broad it is and and it's just
sort of seems to expand as much as an
imagination you know and that's really
exciting to be part of it was amazing to
be out there and watch all these movies
being unveiled in their various forms I
can't believe I'm a part of it it was I
was I felt more like a fanboy today than
a director you know it was awesome
I was backstage it was hard to see but
it looked like there was a big smooth
Big Smoke reveal you know smokescreen
reveal of Benedict as as Doctor Strange
and of course when he's when when the
light came on it was like one of the
Beatles was it was in Hall H you know it
was mayhem it was awesome
people loved him it's incredible you
know and watching all those all those
movies and watched every panel and every
one of them got me excited I was really
moved by the Black Panther cast and
director of talking about the movie I
felt like something brand-new is coming
that I just have never seen anything
like and I and I lost my voice screaming
at the guardians to materials because
they baby grew it was like the greatest
thing I've ever seen you know
you